[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today as we
talk about careers and jobs with him and
life and so forth with me and
ken together this is launch day around
ramsey borrowed future the documentary
is available as of now you can watch it
on
apple tv on google play and on amazon
prime or borrowed future dot com if
you're a teacher and you would like to
show this student loan expose to your
students after they see it i promise you
they will go to college without debt
it will uh scare them straight
and uh we're here to stir up a holy
ruckus it's what we do around here and i
can promise you this uh this documentary
will uh
it's not gonna be some people not happy
when they see what we did to them yeah
because we expose the underbelly of some
of these places that uh have been
misbehaving for years and all shows up
in this documentary you will enjoy it
it's riveting
it's very very very well done borrowed
future anywhere great docs are found
so ken the wall street journal reads the
irs wants to look at your bank account
on your next trip to the atm imagine
that uncle sam is looking over your
shoulder as if your annual tax filing
wasn't invasive enough the biden
administration would like to look at
your checking account
charles reddig the commissioner of the
internal revenue service wants banks to
report annual cash flows for ordinary
account holders treasury secretary janet
yellen is promoting the plan and the
house ways and means committee is
debating whether to include this mandate
in the democrats 3.5 trillion dollar
spending bill mr yellen says the
reporting will help to catch wealthy tax
dodgers in a recent letter to the
committee she said the plan would reveal
opaque income
streams that disproportionately accrue
to the top
yeah the re the wealthy are evil and i'm
sure they're all hiding their money in
the bank you stupid woman
seriously
well this is uh this is unbelievable had
had i not seen that this was an actual
article i would have thought this was a
spoof from the onion
this is so unbelievably outrageous
that the federal government is kicking
around the idea of being able to look
into our bank accounts let me tell you
something this is going to get nasty
right here because uh there's there's
always another way around it every time
government tries to move and pivot to
take away our personal freedom uh people
figure it out and i hope some bankers
are paying attention right now because
if i i i can you imagine something can
you imagine that this would not help
deposits
that's what i'm saying yeah it's going
to disrupt and destroy an industry i got
to tell you the irs plans to review
every account above a 600 balance
or because that's the people that are
these are the wealthy tax dodgers here
well there's the catch it's not about
wealthy people it's about everybody yeah
it's about control
again it's time for some pitch forks to
come out i got a little bit of a little
bit of a
probably a couple of uh torches to go
with the pitchforks yes it's also a
privacy breach waiting to happen not
long ago the confidential tax records of
just bezos mike bloomberg and other
wealthy americans were exposed by
pro-publica
whoever leaked or hacked those records
committed a crime but the irs has
revealed nothing from its promised
investigation adding bank account info
to the irs trove would dis risk the
disclosure of savings and spending
information of political adversaries in
the same way no that would never happen
23 state treasurers and auditors signed
a letter last month opposing the plan
calling it one of the largest
infringements of data
privacy in our nation's history you
think
by the way watch this watch how this
might just flood the cryptocurrency
thing becoming an outside fringe thing
to an actual everyday thing that's why
this thing is out there i'm not
endorsing it at all i don't do anything
with it i want to be very clear but
that's where this is coming from
because of this government overreach you
watch it it's just gonna if this happens
or even tries to happen it's gonna
create a tidal wave of of mistrust and
all kinds of problems it's laughable
it's so absurd
it really is it's it's mind-blowing that
that they think that this could actually
happen
yeah and and you know i would think
that probably one of the more powerful
lobbying groups
even for democrats would be the bankers
abs that's why i laugh and i would think
that they would put their big heel on
this and grind
because this is going to create
a lot of cost for them
because they have to build systems to
report this to comply
this is like this is a billions and
billions of dollars of cost for the
banking industry yeah
yeah the the this my god if you got 750
joe biden wants to know it oh yeah and
first of all let me just say this i i
have no this is opinion i just don't
think this has any legs to at all it's
so ridiculous
but the emperor is officially not
wearing clothes that's where we are
right now this is such an unfortunate
transition
[Laughter]
yes on top of everything else he's
taking his clothes suit needs earnings
don't do that yes it does don't do that
yeah it's just so absurd that this that
this policy would even be floating no
it's just
but it's
you know it goes along with a lot of the
covet overreach and some of these other
things that are overreaching
constitutional rights
um
and it's been going on for some time yes
and uh
just how much
before people bow up on it um i think
this would do apparently there's a
weather problem with southwest air right
now yeah weather the weather everywhere
southwest air is flying is bad yeah and
so uh they're struggling with weather
and everywhere they land there's a
problem yeah
so yeah
this is gonna this has
these
statements and policies and supposed
things even if you don't implement them
if you just toss it out there like a
trial balloon that has a grenade
attached to it uh it still has
implications
that's a great point you know reverbs
through these industries that's
absolutely a great point dave this is a
threat to privacy
a threat
right now it's a threat it's not an
attack yet but it's a threat and i don't
know if there's anything more private
than our bank accounts you start talking
about people's money
i mean we're talking you've been doing
this for a long time we're talking
crazy emotions around
oh your money and the privacy of that
yeah this is a threat to privacy that's
what this is yeah it's like a a banana
republic where you can't trust the
banking system so you have to keep your
money under a mattress
and you have to stay off the grid
because you can't it's not trustworthy
they're correct why they steal the cheat
and you know some of these crazy
countries and if we're are we going to
devolve into that with this kind of
movement out of the federal government
of course the good news is we've got a
group of governors
on several of these issues that are
saying uh your overreach doesn't extend
across our state line
we're not going to allow it and then
we've got another group of governors
that went oh yeah we're all in uh
whatever you want to do
we're with you big joe
yeah this is out of control
out of control the tyranny is uh is real
so yeah just let them poke around in
everybody's bank account
not to mention how much that costs not
to mention how much you do but every
time you get ready to move your money
that you earned they want to know about
it
[Music]
yeah we'll see how that works out
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
michael's with us in tampa florida hey
michael welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys how you doing great man what's
up
hey so
um
i'm having trouble deciding if i need to
take um this new job along with the
challenges the schedule would have with
me and my wife um
we just had like a big rent increase in
the entire tampa bay area
and the job
was pos was going to pay me probably
about eight grand more
walking into the door
and i wouldn't know if i should take the
job
why would you not take the job what are
you wondering about
um so
i have a older child
from a previous relationship
and she comes over
every other weekend
and it would disrupt
my time with her as well as my wife and
i are disagreeing about
you know i have one son
and um she wants him to play sports and
i do too but
by the games being on the weekend i
wouldn't be able to be there
and we've kind of been bickering back
and forth
about that
and i'm trying to get her to hold off
you know to agree to hold on for it but
i'm having a hard time yeah so are you
guys in tough shape financially to where
this eight thousand dollar bump is
really really needed
how is it going to affect you guys if
you don't take the bump
besides all the relationship stuff
i know that you guys recommend 25
um
our rent shouldn't be that
uh but i mean to take home pay and the
rent increase
will probably put it at about 30 percent
what do you make a year
combined last year we made 98.
okay
so you're talking about an eight percent
increase or seven percent increase
and
[Music]
your dispute is
you would be working every weekend
yes
doing what what are you going to be
doing
i'm a truck driver for dr pepper right
now and i have a better opportunity at a
food service distribution as a food
truck driver okay
and uh will you be working weekends then
the rest of your life
yeah because i have a friend of mine
that works there and i was communicating
with him about it and i spoke with his
direct supervisor and he kept it
you know on he was honest with me he
said this he said he's been working
saturday for 18 years he says i hate it
you know and i just i have guys quit all
the time because they have kids that
want to
you know
play ball and they want to be there and
they can't
michael is it is it possible i just want
to know what your opinion is is it
possible do you think that you could
find another job making 8 000
even more than 8 000 more
where you don't have to work weekends
it's it's very tough um i've tried
tanker and hazmat because i do have
those endorsements on my license but
those guys work saturday and sunday and
evening time i've turned down
countless jobs even up to paying 90
grand because they want you to work in
the evening and it's saturday and sunday
are these all driving related jobs where
you're driving yes yeah but again i want
to put that question back to you i think
you've limited yourself
because you've got a background you may
enjoy driving i think you have to open
up your possibilities right here to say
well wait a second i've got some
experience and i've got some skill
and it's very transferable i can do a
whole lot more than just drive a truck
and you are making a pretty decent
household income together but you can
increase this i think you've got to open
yourself up to what's out there and when
you begin to look for those things you
will see those things and you got to get
busy on this because taking this job is
not about the 8 000 bump
you're gonna be very miserable
relationally because you're gonna miss
your kid you're gonna put pressure on
your wife to not let the kid play sports
and all that stuff and that's just a
bunch of relationship turmoil that is
related to you boxing yourself into this
is the only thing i can do
and i think that's the challenge and to
begin to see what else you can do uh
that is a much different schedule that
doesn't require you to work weekends the
rest of your life this is a great market
right now to be looking
and you've got to just harness all of
that
negative energy and turn it into i'm
going to look for something else that
does
fit my relationship goals as well
because it's out there
yeah and this is the moment um because
with all the stuff happening in the
economy
one of the issues is logistics meaning
delivery by trucks
and uh we're you know we've got ships
that they can't get into port because
they can't get the trucks to put the
stuff on
and so i'm not suggesting you start
driving over the road i'm just saying
that truck driving is at a premium right
now
and so no i would not take this other
job but no i would not stay where i am
either that's correct and so i'm gonna
do what ken said i'm gonna expand my uh
uh the the color the page you're
coloring on is not big enough you need a
bigger page and you need to draw a
better picture of where your future is
going to be uh hang on the line michael
i would love to give him a code a link
and a code to the get clear career
assessment which is going to help you
see things you've never seen before it's
a wonderful tool taking less than 20
minutes it'll help you see purpose in
your work but more than that give you
some real possibilities you can see what
you have to offer to this world because
you've got a lot to offer
mark is in los angeles hey mark welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
dave i have a legacy journey question my
wife and i are on baby step seven and we
have a nest egg of about four million
three million in iras and one million in
a taxable brokerage account
we'll live off the interest you know
with the goal of preserving the nest egg
as an inheritance for my daughters
here's my question as we manage this
nest egg i'm currently planning to
deplete the money in the iras and grow
the money in the brokerage account over
time
with a goal of leaving the kids a
portfolio that's a hundred percent
brokerage account and no ira money
so their inheritance isn't encumbered
with any government strings or tax bonds
or anything and what i wondered was is
this the right strategy yes if so how
you would recommend i manage it to
achieve it yeah i mean you've got the
idea and it's just a matter of drawing
down on the thing
uh fast enough to keep
uh you know
that you hit the perfect mark right
where there's nothing left except the uh
brokerage account when you get to
retirement so
uh that your your money that you are
generous with while you're alive to
other things uh your money that you are
living off of all comes out of that ira
because that is it doesn't create an
inheritance tax the ira doesn't but it
is taxable because it's a traditional
ira it's going to be taxed uh as an
inherited ira or inherited 401k uh and
so yeah you're right you you you're on
the right track but there's not a magic
number to it if you know when you're
gonna die you can figure it out easy
yeah right but you know just start to
start running your numbers and
and depleted exactly at that moment but
you don't have to worry about that
if you can just minimize the damage or
minimize the process that they have to
screw with the government
by by using this strategy it's very very
wise i think you're way ahead of the
curve that's some really good thinking
on your part
really good thinking beautiful idea i
hadn't even thought of that actually
really no i haven't i may need to think
about that myself
well that's good that's kind of a nice
thing i've done a whole bunch of other
things to keep money off the estate plan
right uh from a state tax standpoint
but um but i haven't thought about the
stinking 401k which is sitting over
there it's a monster right so is it
about the pace by which he has to draw
it down there's no i mean well you've
got to use it up because anything he
doesn't use up is going to be taxed
right but you could there's nothing that
keeps you from pulling out of a certain
sums at some point and certain something
i mean you can do it discriminately
you're going to pay taxes on it he's
going to pay taxes on it or they're
going to pay taxes on it right you're
not going to get out of the taxes but
it's not a state tax it's income tax
right on the 401 k
and um yeah this is one of those uh tax
dodges that the wealthy do
this is why the rs irs needs to get in
our bank account yeah this is exactly
evil because we you know we worked our
whole lives and we actually built up
something of our own money and already
paid taxes on it once and then they want
to get us again
pay your fair share you you full wealthy
people evil wealthy person you
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage don and paula are with
us hey guys how are you good
where do you guys live bemidji minnesota
all right welcome to nashville so good
to have you how much debt have you guys
paid off
135 thousand dollars way to go and how
long did this take
oh 26 months good for you and your range
of income during that time
148 000 to 158 000. good what do you
guys do for a living uh i'm a physical
therapist
i work for large credit union okay very
cool what kind of debt was the 135 000
uh we had three credit cards uh home
equity lot of credit
uh two vehicles a camper and a massive
student loan oh man a big old student
loan huh massive how long you guys been
married 18 years wow
so what happened two years ago they put
you on this ramsey journey
we actually heard about you back in 2007
a friend of us had given uh gifted us
your dvds uh we read them we listened to
them thought it was great at the time
though we only had the massive school
loan the mortgage
so it just didn't stick
fast forward life happened and uh
you know i
paul paul always took care of the money
so in 2018 you know all of a sudden she
comes to me and says
you need to quit going out for lunch
well okay well thankfully i only live
seven minutes from lunch or from work
so i would go home and do dishes and
laundry and go back to work not a big
deal
so a few months go by and she uh
she says we need to cut cable we can't
afford it we can't afford 100 a month oh
okay well begrudgingly i did
so
um
in march of
2018 i'm working away and
that morning i get a co i get a phone
call from her
she was traveling a lot for work and she
says you need to get out of this podcast
we need to do this now and it was your
podcast
hopped on never looked back
so we
we took our credit cards from april
and itemized everything
and uh in the month of march dave
we spent
uh 1 225 out in restaurants
and 225 dollars out in coffee shops wow
i never know where your retirement was
going you were eating it never again no
and we never looked back wow it was game
on game over wow
wow yeah you don't do anything when he
jumps he jumps into the deep end
that's right
wow that's pretty impressive
very cool
so
you went wide open then for the next two
years yep game over these numbers are
pretty impressive i mean you've been on
beans and rice yup yes we have i mean
you had to have broke people making fun
of you
we had a lot of naysayers absolutely i
bet you did still a lot of haters yeah
unreal
and um but now you're free and they're
not so here we go look at me now how you
like me now yeah
i like it yeah good for you guys i'm so
proud of you thank you very very well
done how's it feel to be free
unbelievable it's
it is absolutely crazy
yeah i mean the emotion is all over you
done and it's powerful stuff
where's that coming from is it the
sacrifice is it the future is it all of
it together that you're feeling in this
moment well it's just
the feeling in 2019 you know
basically being normal living in an
outhouse and
now i'm in a penthouse kitchen's college
funded retirement fully funded
it's done i don't have to worry about
money anymore it's over wow
very cool
wow so paula what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is now that
you guys did it
you know i think for me
well a the budget because it was crazy
you know always being in charge of the
finances and paying off the credit or
trying to pay off the credit cards and
we didn't have the money to pay off
their credit cards and and then we did a
budget
and it's like holy crap we have extra
money to put toward this debt where did
this come from well it wasn't going out
to eat and the coffee shops and so the
budget was huge but i think the thing
that made the difference in 2019 versus
07 when we initially heard about you
was
we had a y you know in 07 we didn't have
the kids we didn't have to worry about
college
and now we have the kids and we
have a lake lot and the goal was to
build a house at the lake lot and
be able to do that when our kids are
still with us and not out of the house
and so i think it's having the budget
but having that big why
so it sounds like you were handling the
money obviously correct and just kind of
giving don instructions
and uh the last instruction you gave him
was uh listen to this podcast which
meant that you no longer got to handle
the money by yourself but you also
didn't have all the weight on your own
shoulders
carrying all the decisions by yourself
and
talk about how important it is or how
you felt when your husband has put his
shoulder up under there and lifted
some of the weight off of you by making
the decisions together
it was it was huge i mean i was the one
that always took care of everything and
all of a sudden don is the one that's
checking the bank account like
500 times a day you lit him on fire
didn't you and he's like oh just so you
know i updated the budget i updated
every dollar um and it's huge and and
honestly it's so nice because
i know that we're both on the same page
you know because back in the day there
were times where we would go out to eat
and he'd be like oh
you know i got this and i look at him
like uh we don't we don't got the money
to got this
now i don't need to worry
yeah so great
all right so so
don you got on board right and it's
obviously you went all in okay
absolutely what was the most extreme
thing you did early on that you look
back on now and you go this this helped
me go from conviction and knowing that
we have to do it to this got me really
going
um
you know there was a
an instance a couple weeks in where she
had called me and
she was down uh
shopping with one of her sisters and
she had asked me she could buy a
sweatshirt and i said no you cannot buy
a sweatshirt you can use one of my
sweatshirts i have twelve of them that i
never wear
so you can go ahead and use one of mine
if you need a sweatshirt we do not need
a sweatshirt wow the bravery to say that
my man how did that go i want to hear
the rest of that story
well i told i was shopping with my
sister she was in town and she's like oh
paula this is really cute you've got to
get this and i was like no that's that's
not in the budget and she's like oh come
on paula it is a sweatshirt and i was
like
i can't it's not in the budget and she
said fine i'll call up dawn i'll ask don
and i said oh the system
you can ask don i know what he's gonna
tell you he's gonna tell you no way and
she's like he is not and she got off the
phone and she goes don told me you
couldn't get the sweatshirt i was like i
told you he was gonna say no
nice
whoa
that's discipline though hey that means
that's it that's when listen if you live
like no one else later you can live like
no one else yeah and you know when you
make 158 000 a year and you don't have
any debt you can get a sweatshirt yeah
by the way i would like to point out at
this
appropriate time don you should probably
buy her a sweatshirt yeah
one that one that says nashville on it
while you're here she's earned it this
woman earned a sweatshirt
we're we're gonna we're gonna go all in
on that i think so matter of fact ken's
gonna buy you there it is start hey why
not
with my money
you guys are fun thank you so much
congratulations we're very very proud of
you you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages let's get them
up into the shot
we have garrett and owen who are 12. and
mallory who is 10. all right
very very good most awesome very cool we
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's a your next chapter in your story
for sure you've changed your whole
legacy guys as you said you've got a
great why uh you changed your life for
your kids and you changed their life in
the process very cool stuff also copy
the total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody one of those people
that was making fun of you maybe maybe
maybe we can help them out that's a good
idea so very well done all right don and
paula garrett owen and mallory from
minnesota
135
000 paid off in 26 months making 148 to
158 you are looking at life change right
in front of you count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done right there baby
yeah freedom
[Laughter]
it doesn't get any better
listen when you work that hard and you
sacrifice that deep you'll never go back
no you can't hear it never go back i'm
not going to talk to them later they go
well dave you know we sort of fell off
and went and bought a car on the jet
you're not going to hear that from don
no don has changed he's done yes he is
he's stick a fork in him he's done yes
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-522
brian is with us in boulder colorado hey
brian how are you
hey dave good how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
well pleasure to be speaking with you um
i wanted to talk to you about uh we
recently refinanced our home to a
15-year
mortgage
um but it puts us over
your recommended 25
of our take-home pay it puts us more at
like 35
and
just wondering if we should be looking
for
a
cheaper home
well here's the thing the whole reason
for that ratio
of 25 is for people not to sign up for
something that causes them
to be so pinched in their budget that
they're tempted to go into debt for
things they should have been saving up
for
in other words if the house payment is
pinching your budget so tight that every
little thing that comes up looks like
it's going to be a new debt then that's
being house poor
and that that's the thing so 35 doesn't
kill you particularly if you are
on a career path where you're going to
see your income come up and it's not
going to be 35 percent long for long
it's going to be 30 percent and then
later on it's going to be 25 so i don't
know that we have to panic about this
but it's it's just a matter of don't do
not be continuously engaging in
a process that that makes you broke
that makes your monthly cash flow
pinched and so you know as long as you
have a good career path and you think
you're going to see your income coming
up i wouldn't panic and jump ship on it
uh at this stage now if you're going to
go buy a home
don't do that
okay don't don't go buy a home and take
on 35 gold well my income's going to go
up now that's just that's you know
that's twisting my words that's not what
i'm saying but you're already in a house
are we going to sell the house move go
through all that expense when in 24 or
36 months your ratios would have been
all right anyway because your income
came up no i'm not going to do that
but don't go signing up for these things
in the future that put you in a pinch
that's the whole point of the thing
so ken the great resignation is underway
a lot of people 55 percent of americans
one survey says are thinking about
changing jobs actively right now
couldn't be a better time for us to
launch a book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to getting work you love
i think your book's timing might be just
uh maybe the best i've ever seen
yeah we we believe so because the people
are changing for a variety of reasons so
whether or not you just want to get
promoted make more money you're doing
what you really enjoy now you just want
to move up get a bigger shovel to get
through the baby steps or
you're just showing up to a nine to five
and you feel like you're just miserable
when you pull up in the parking lot
monday morning
or you just want to find what is that
meaningful work this book really helps
everybody who wants to work on purpose
who wants more than a j-o-b who wants to
make income and impact and the seven
stages that we unpacked in the book no
matter who you are where you are we'll
get you there and that's why we're so
excited about it everybody knows that
there's something they're supposed to do
but they just wonder how do i get there
is it possible and the answer is yes
there is a clear path yeah just a couple
weeks before we ship these books or in
pre-sale right now if you want a hundred
dollars worth of extra items including
the e-book including the um the
audiobook including a whole bunch of
other things go ahead and get the book
now for 20
and you get over a hundred dollars worth
of bonus tools resume templates and
guides a video course that'll coach you
through the interview process all of
this
paycheck from paycheck to purpose at
ramsey solutions go ahead and pre-order
it now our question of the today comes
from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings with free samples free
shipping and the new promos they run all
the time you will uh well you save even
more use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from ahmet in
michigan i'm 30 years old i work for a
local credit union and we get quarterly
reviews i've met expectation for my next
review and i've upped my skill set i
want to ask for a sizable raise after
working really hard during the lockdown
where half of my team worked remotely
during that time one co-worker and i
have been in the office whenever it was
open and i recently found out that one
of my co-workers is making 15 to 17 000
more than me and when this person takes
time off i'm responsible for making sure
their tasks get done the only person who
knows how much i work
uh how much work i put in is my manager
i currently work over 60 hours a week i
do love my job in the company i'm
working for but it is hard when i know
i'm putting in more work than everyone
else and getting paid less well we've
heard this question before and
unfortunately this the psychology around
this kind of information that you've
gotten is really hard to overcome
because you are now aware and you are
comparing yourself and that is a very
dangerous dangerous place to be in
because you can't do much about this in
this situation when you go into your
next review uh you know
leveraging this information isn't going
to help you i wouldn't do it what i
would talk about is a growth plan i
would lay out
how much you love the company as you as
you put in this email and that you want
to be here and you want to grow not just
professionally but financially but you
lead with professional growth what are
some areas that i can get better in
where i'm a little bit weak what are
some skills some tools i can add to my
tool belt
that will allow me to
a get more responsibility drive greater
value b and then c grow financially as
well that's the posture by which you
approach this so that your leaders get
some buy-in they see your hunger but
also your humility and that's all you
can do and if you've got healthy
leadership they're going to respond and
they're going to talk about a growth
plan and then measure the growth that's
tied to compensation if they are not
going to address this and they kick the
can
down the road this is a sign
that it may be time for you to move on
and where you see a ladder and not a lid
yeah that's the thing and so there is
nothing wrong with saying
in my mind and you can correct me ken um
how can i add value that will make you
want to give me more money because i'd
like to see some more income but i want
i want to be worth it yes
instead of i deserve this because so and
so that's right if you say i did i
deserve this because 60 hours i deserve
this because so and so you know the
entitlement i deserve this thing
um is uh one of the most negative
possible emotions
uh that you can that you can generate
and you've gotten yourself kind of down
in that hole a little bit here yeah a
little bit of a pity party going on in
the email there oh sure and uh and
rightly so
but still you know
it's the wrong posture for you to get
ahead you're not supposed to know what
your co-worker makes
and this is why
because it's almost impossible to not
deal positively with that and that's why
i laid it out when you sit with your
leader you don't ask for a raise you ask
for a growth plan you lead with as you
notice what i said first where can i get
better what are some areas where you
where you think i can how can i add
value that once makes you want to give
me if some i'm not i mean i own ramsey
solutions if you come in my office and
i'm doing a review with you or whatever
or we're talking or even you just came
in randomly and said listen
i i'd like to make more money and
uh the way i want to do that is i want
to be worth more how can i be worth more
how can i add value versus i actually
had a guy come in my office many years
ago had more degrees than a thermometer
over-educated fool
and said uh you know
show me his resume you know a guy like
me that has this many degrees
we usually make like a lot more than i
make now
and i said well you know you're working
a small business son and he said what do
you mean i said well small business
works like this your raise is effective
when you are
i don't give a crap about your degrees
when you do something i'll share it with
you
that's how it works in a small business
but but you know i got a degree so i got
or i got six degrees so you know what
are you a black belt yeah i mean come on
no
so um that didn't that doesn't that
didn't play in dave's office no and it
won't play anybody else's either by the
way exactly right not because i'm a jerk
it's just that's the way it is
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five again this is
launch day for the new documentary
borrowed future is available any great
doc where any great documentaries are
seen
for instance you can see it on apple tv
you can rent it for 4.99 on any of these
locations including app google play
uh apple tv uh
amazon prime thank you there new there's
another one yeah i gotta decide which
one i'm gonna watch it maybe i'll just
do all three of them well we're number
two right now we launched it this
morning yes we're number two among
documentaries on apple right now that's
great so it's already coming out of the
gate pretty strong
and i got to tell you when you guys
watch this thing you're gonna tell
everybody you know they have to watch it
it is amazing yeah so proud of our team
borrowed future how student loans are
killing the american dream out today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
where he talks about careers and jobs in
author of the number one best-selling
book the proximity principle and the new
book from paycheck to purpose he is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five samantha is with us in
san francisco hi samantha how are you hi
i'm doing good how are you today better
than we deserve what's up
um well i wanted to ask you guys
especially at ken about
possibly
giving me some direction on where i
should go
career-wise at this point
i currently am in an electrical
apprenticeship it's actually the family
trade
a bunch of electricians but
um i'm starting to realize that it's not
really for me i'm a single mom and so
there's a lot of pressure when it comes
to trying to balance that as well as
balance
this career as well it just
seems as though i keep having these
roadblocks you know put in front of me
and so it doesn't seem like i'm going
down the right path and because i'm
starting to feel that way i've been
thinking about some other career options
that might be good for me and i just
want to make sure that if i do change
careers that i do go down from the right
path instead of you know walking down
another path and realizing that it's not
for me again sure
uh what what's the big idea there is
there a leading idea in the clubhouse
right now
yeah well i mean i have two two ideas um
one of them is actually
your idea i was thinking about being
that i'm here in the silicon valley area
going to betheltech and trying to get
a certification with them to become a ux
designer because there's a lot of open
jobs for that here
so that was one option and then if if
nothing else mattered and i followed my
heart it would be i would try to go do
producing um i really like the idea of
that i did a lot of stage management in
high school so i did a lot of the live
production type management and
background back behind the scenes type
of
work and you know i really do love that
kind of work but i understand that that
would take me getting a little bit more
qualified in the professional setting
before i could actually make that a
career yeah what does that look like
just fast forward real quick
take me up the ladder i have a good idea
of that industry but you've got a better
idea what would that look like if
everything was just equal and we could
fast forward you there you're making the
money you want to make what would you be
doing where would you be doing it
yeah i mean i i love the idea of you
know the producing live events um i
thought a lot about doing professional
stage management for a long time but i
don't think that the purpose would
really be behind professional stage
management i'm in live theater so i was
thinking more like live events that help
people you know
talk shows and that kind of deal okay so
i'm glad you gave me that specific i
want to encourage you on something there
is a path to get to that um and i will
tell you that
you're already qualified to do that you
know the fact that you've done some
production work in the background i mean
excuse me in your background your career
background
you are uh qualified now if you've got
the talent of organization and detail
management you've got some good personal
skills and connecting with people
and you're a good coordinator is the
word that's coming to mind you can do
that and you can get in if you do a
great job you can do well in fact i've
got a friend who lives in the nashville
area who now he's been doing this 25
years who now gets called for just every
la award show that you can imagine i see
him on tv all the time he's a
professional stage manager now that's
more wow that's very cool yeah so i just
want to share with you that that's
possible okay so now it's about i'm a
single mom i want to get out of this
trade that's not right being an
electrician that's kind of not my jam
i'm thinking about technology
as a ux designer i got to tell you i
like the idea of you moving into a good
solid day job
okay that takes care of you and the
child or the children and we got some
great stability and then you begin to
work
uh live events on the side that's going
to be some weekends maybe a little bit
of travel but if you can travel some and
get in that live event industry and as a
contractor and we at ramsey solutions
hire
some not many but some live event
producers you can get in that way and
begin to build it and with that
technology background and degree and
qualification
i think it gives you i think it's both
and i think that'll be a really nice
stable path because you're gonna have to
build relationships over time
and get in and then once you realize i'm
in and i can make the income i need
then i step into that so i think you've
got either or uh if you can make the
connections now
and get in the live event space and make
what you need to make i'd say go now if
you need to build up to that
then i would look at technologies a very
safe day job
brian is in jonesboro arkansas hey brian
welcome to the ramsey show
hey ken it's an honor to talk to you you
too um
i've always had a low self-esteem and i
recently went through a separation in
divorce
how do i
throw my net worth without confusing it
with salesforce
well let me reverse that
who
builds a big net worth and what type of
person builds a big net worth and
confuses it with self-worth
not sure
someone with a low self-esteem
no no not at all no because low
self-esteem is not you know you don't
confuse network if you have a high net
worth and a low self-esteem you're not
you're not confusing it
so that's not the case the person that
becomes what we're saying is someone
becomes wealthy and they become a jerk
or they become power hungry or they
become they think they're all that
and so what they are is they're
spiritually and emotionally
psychologically shallow
they have no spiritual depth to their
life
they have no psychological depth to
their life and let me help you with this
a person who asks this question
is not prone to that
yeah the person i'm talking about would
never ask this question
they would never go i'm confusing my net
worth with my self-worth i'm really i'm
all that because i've got a million
dollars you know that's that's that's
somebody that made that confusion and
that's a shallow entitled little jerk
you know
and whether they're a 58 year old little
jerk or 18 you're a little jerk but um
you're not going to have that problem
brian i i just hear failure all over you
yeah you've been through such health it
sounds like some tough stuff and you're
starting to question how valuable you
are and so i think i'm going to give you
two practical answers to your question
number one
you need to get around some people who
know you really well
who can remind you
of how valuable you are to them
secondly i want you to just do a little
self exercise and just begin to get to
know brian again and ask yourself what
do i do really well what if people
complimented me on in my life i think i
messed that up
i think he was saying i've got a low net
worth so i think i have a low self-worth
he is he's he's i was flipping it i went
the other way well i was going where
you're going
he's struggling financially and in his
relationships and he's going i'm having
a hard time seeing if i'm valuable
because i don't have any money yeah okay
well your value is intrinsic your value
as a person your value as a human has
nothing to do with your money that's
right but that's just uh that's a normal
transaction when you've gotten the crap
beat out of you like you have with the
loss of relationships and everything
else so one other question i'm sorry i
completely blew that no it's okay but
brian here's what i want you to
apologize into you oh i know
but i'm just saying it's okay but brian
here's what i want you to do i want you
to find some people to add value to
volunteer go love on somebody go do
something valuable for somebody
and feel the value that you be of help
to someone serve and that will raise
your self-worth and it is independent of
your net worth i'm so sorry i messed
that up
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage jimmy's with us hi jimmy
how are you dave i'm great how are you
better than i deserve sir so where do
you live white plains new york white
plains all right very cool welcome to
nashville and uh how much debt have you
paid off jimmy i have paid off just over
97 dollars very cool how long did that
take you sir just about five years
love it and uh your range of income
during that time talking about pay after
tax um 53 to start and finishing up at
78. good for you what do you do for a
living i am a training specialist i work
for a large engineering company um so if
your employees here at ramsay have to
take any of those computerized
e-learning modules i make those for the
company that i work for ah
okay good for you very cool what kind of
debt was your 97 000 it was a car and
two student loans one private one
federal ah
okay
so what put you on this ramsey journey
thing five years ago so in my family any
time you have a question about money my
cousin stephen he's a little older than
me he's in his 50s
he's the guy you talk to about money
quick background on him he's in his
early 50s owns a mini mansion in north
carolina free and clear is retired
already after putting two kids through
college so that's who you want to be
when you grow up gotcha i had a question
for because of steve yeah cousin steve
so i had a question for him something
about my 401k back when i was new with
my current company so i called him and i
was asking him whatever it was that i
had to ask him about the 401k and he
goes hold on time out stop for a minute
let's take a step back you just finished
your masters right yes steve okay how
much student loan debt do you have
hanging out i told him the
embarrassingly high number of student
loan debt that i had and he goes all
right have you heard of dave ramsey and
i said
actually yes and the reason that i have
was because my mother actually had the
exact copy of total money makeover that
i brought with me here today sitting on
her coffee table at her house it's a
great coaster it really it really was i
think i used it a few times myself
before before i realized what exactly it
was so my apologies for that that's all
good it's it's america's greatest
coaster
so anyway so he goes read that book and
then
talk to me later and we'll see how you
doing i read that book
and it literally completely changed my
life and i'm not just saying that to
blow smoke dave
really i never thought about money the
same way again wow i like cousin steve
yeah yeah he's my greatest promo guy way
to go steve that's cool
he kind of handled it like i think you
would he was like hold on let's just go
back he just cut him off and said no no
no no no no i'm going to talk to you
about your 401k until you read your
mother's coaster that's right i love him
to get the coaster off the coffee table
and i don't think we even finished the
conversation about the 401k from there
on out it was all about the debt yeah
just all and you got done you got done
and five years later here you sit all of
it's gone car
student loans everything sitting with a
master's degree your mattresses and what
industrial and organizational psychology
which he uses every day yes he does
fabulous yeah and thus you and thus you
are doing that that's beautiful i like
it very cool very cool jimmy i love it
how's it feel to be free oh it's
tremendous dave it's like having a 400
pound monkey no longer on your back
[Laughter]
absolutely
absolutely what do you tell people
you're a trainer what's the key to
getting out of debt ignore and drown out
all the noise as you're going through
this process i mean i live in new york i
meet a lot of people that wear very
expensive suits and sound like they
really know what they're talking about
when it comes to money i've had people
try to get me into cryptocurrency people
try to get me into pyramid schemes i
mean all kinds of things that we're
going to take away from my total money
makeover debt-free journey
and sometimes they make points that like
make sense for a second and then you're
like wait a minute no i listen to dave
ramsey that's what i'm going to do
so it's drowning out all that noise
staying the course and really just being
focused on it wow submitting to the plan
exactly and stick to the plan stick to
the plan stick to the plan good for you
very well done sir wow this is powerful
it is i i'm curious is there a moment
you can look back to or you you said
okay i i caught some serious momentum uh
or did you just from day one you were a
bull and you never let up
the momentum and this is where i think
the snowball method is really really
effective it was i had one of the
student loans was for three thousand so
that was easy cash then came the car i
had i think eleven thousand left on the
car at that point once i paid off the
car and now i had 280 from the car plus
30 for that other one 330 which for me
back then was a lot of money at the time
now that i had that free to apply
towards the largest debt which was the
largest student loan that was the point
where it was like all right now i'm
really making progress now we're really
going to see this thing take off awesome
wow how big how important is that to
experience that momentum in this journey
it's essential because if you don't feel
it if you don't feel it here your head
is not going to listen to what's in here
if what's in here is not there if that
makes sense does it make sense man
you're preaching that somebody ought to
tweet that that's phenomenal what you
just said that's really good very well
done very well done congratulations jim
i'm proud of you thank you dave and ken
proud of cousin steve
oh he'll be so happy because i'm going
to show him the clip once this is so
he'll be that's awesome he'll laugh for
sure i love it was he one of your
cheerleaders as you went through this
absolutely he was of course my my family
mother father sister they were all very
supportive but who i really have to
thank is the ramsey community because
they were my accountability partners i
mean if you notice i'm standing up here
all by myself i don't have a spouse i
don't have kids there was nobody to
really hold me accountable for doing all
this per se
but when i turned on youtube three four
times a week to watch the replay from
the show just hearing the phone calls
and and
seeing the reactions and the emotion
from people when they did their screams
and just hearing all their stories
that's what kind of held me accountable
so i did this not only for myself but
kind of also as what i felt was an
obligation to the ramsey community so
thank you to the entire ramsey community
of listeners seriously from my heart to
yours i love it
love this guy this is great what a what
a powerful thing we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you uh a new coaster
for your mom's table and uh a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away so that can be a coaster on someone
else's table hey it but it hangs out
long enough eventually it gets red i'm
i'm going with this plan multi-purpose
it's a long play it's not a short game
yeah it's a long game play but i'm going
with it it's working for me well done
jimmy very well done all right jimmy
from yonkers new york 97 000 paid off in
five years making
53-78 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three
two
one i'm
[Applause]
i dead it
that is so fun
uh
i think that whole uh segment was
tweetable oh i know i mean that that
screen right i want to tackle somebody
and i don't tackle anybody but i wanna
he's ready to go i mean the sheer
passion uh from this guy how about the
shout out to the entire community and i
think that's a really interesting point
that there's a whole bunch of people
that we get the privilege to serve
and and in serving them they end up
encouraging each other it really is the
community it it's it's amazing you know
all the people in ramsey plus and all
the people that have come to the events
all the years all the people that are on
the facebook page all
it's amazing to see that here's a single
guy who shouted out all the other people
he came in contact with on the same
journey yep that's really cool and
there's that um well it gives you
permission
to do stuff that that the rest of the
culture is not doing
when you look around you go okay there's
there's about a bazillion other smart
people doing what i'm doing exactly
right uh and yes there's a bunch of
crazies out there in the toxic culture
but um but but but there isn't this
oasis of humans that are engaged in
transformation they're engaged in doing
the work the hard work of change that's
right and changing is hard
wow get yourself a community even if
it's on the facebook page uh or on the
youtube channel get in community it's uh
it's vital way to go jimmy yeah proud of
you man good stuff way to go cousin
steve
i love it love it love it love it
everybody needs a cousin steve most
people don't have one though
that's a privilege right there i feel
like we should get cousin steve on the
line james i mean wouldn't that guy be a
great interview at some point
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
blake and macy are with us hey guys how
are you we're good how are you better
than we deserve where do you live
uh we live in dallas texas all right
welcome to nashville and all the way up
here to do a debt free scream how much
have you paid off we have paid off 66
147
cool how long did that take about 15
months good for you and your range of
income during that time so we started
out at 133 000 and then at the end of
the 15 it was a 143 000. cool what do
y'all do for a living
i'm a mechanical engineer and then i'm
an escrow officer
you're a what an escrow officer oh okay
cool great very good what kind of debt
was this 66 000 it was about at four
credit cards uh with that we
financed our wedding our honeymoon uh
just
about everything uh yeah you name it we
put it on a credit card a really
expensive couch and uh in both of our
cars also so it's four credit cards and
two cars so you're just kind of normal
yeah we were really normal so you come
home from the expensive wedding
honeymoon and expensive cars are sitting
in the driveway how long you've been
married uh almost four years okay so
you've been married a couple years and
you look up and say
uh we got to do something different what
what introduced you to ramsey how did
you get this stuff going so my sister
and brother-in-law actually had paid off
a lot of
over 175 thousand dollars a couple years
ago and it was thanksgiving of 2019 and
we just found out we were pregnant and
so um and i just talking to her you know
at casual thanksgiving dinner and i was
just kind of like well we we have all
this debt and we don't really know what
to what to do but we i just i showed an
interest in wanting to pay it off and so
she just very gently mentioned you and
your podcast and she was just like this
is easy to listen to you know on the way
to work or while you're working out or
whatever and so the very next day on our
drive home um we listened to our first
podcast and something just clicked blake
has he was the nerd i'm the free spirit
and he has always been good with money
he tried to put us put us on a budget
right when we first got married and i
laughed and um i was just like no
[Laughter]
no
but after listening i don't know it was
just something about it was just easy to
listen to you and just kind of get what
we needed to you know to get going and
then
it clicked and so that was thanksgiving
and so january of 2020 we started
executing our plan we're like okay this
is what we're going to do you know the
the baby steps everything they my same
sister and brother-in-law gifted us the
total money
money makeover and so we read that
and you know like a week and then we
were pretty gung-ho and then covet
happened a couple months later i was
pregnant um and we were very lucky that
we kept our jobs and um you know we
didn't have to lose any income so that
was a blessing but um so covet actually
helped us because we didn't do anything
we weren't going anywhere
and i was pregnant so it was like we
weren't really going to go out and do
anything anyways and so
that it made it was initially a two-year
goal and we ended up doing it in 15
months wow you blew through it yeah yeah
and it was just it was all the the debt
snowballs it's just it works it gave us
all the momentum in the world so what
was uh maybe one of the most radical
kind of get after it intense things you
guys did in this journey so i think uh
one of the things was uh saying no to
everything so like it was so hard that
you know we're sitting there and all our
friends are going to beautiful trips and
everything or they're wanting to go to
dinner or anything and we were just
having like no i'm sorry we can't and
it was just hard the fear of missing out
type thing but once we got over that and
then i think the probably the one of the
things was we were expecting our first
child and so i wanted to go crazy with
the nursery and and doing all the things
you know that a mom wants to with their
first kid and well that's unusual
no one ever does that yeah and we didn't
have any money because we were paying
off all this debt and so we didn't buy
one piece of furniture for the nursery
we it was everything was given to us or
hand-me-downs or i mean we just we
didn't have to go
use any of our money for our snowball
and turns out two-month-olds aren't that
picky about where they sleep right yeah
right so that was that i think that was
probably one of the hardest yeah that's
hard that's a big deal yeah yeah that's
a big deal not decorating the nursery
except with uh things that folks give
you that's a big deal yeah i like it a
lot but it's a big deal
yeah very cool good for you guys well
you just proved the difference in a need
and what the kid needs a place to sleep
a want is everything you want around
them they don't even know what's there
right it's all about it's all about mom
making a nest and dad making a nest or
dad making momma nest or however that
works but yeah it's uh it's real yeah so
absolutely
and people spend an
amazing amount of money on this stuff
and the baby literally does not care at
all not even a little bit not even a
little bit yeah so way to go you guys
all right what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is uh one of
the things that i think is uh
communication and collaboration but uh
the main thing was the the budget and i
think that every dollar app was just
mind-blowing for us and we sat down
every month and at the beginning of it
you know we assessed what we could do
and then you know at the end of it it
was easy to say no when it was the
category was zero it's sorry and then
and then i would just say going into it
knowing that you know mentally it's a
short-term sacrifice for a long-term
reward i mean if you go into it thinking
oh this is going to be a bree i mean
nobody really thinks it's going to be a
breeze but if you think that it's going
to be easier than it really is
then i think people get stuck a few
months in and they get frustrated and
they're you know they just give up and i
think we very really we just sat down
every month and was just like this is
our goal this is what we want to do and
15 months is literally nothing in the
grand scheme of things and so
and i mean i'm so glad we did that it's
just it's been it's an amazing feeling
especially now having the baby he's 15
months old now and um
it's just it's a it's a whole new world
i can i can't imagine uh still having
that much debt and
also taking care of you know a baby it's
just absolutely yeah absolutely well
congratulations thank you who were your
biggest cheerleaders outside the two of
you
definitely my sister and brother-in-law
that got us on we got started every time
we paid off a credit card we'd send them
a screenshot of it yeah yeah i like it
they celebrated us
through and through and then my parents
and blake's parents and
yeah and even like our friends and
co-workers like everyone was super
supportive they really were cool loved
the journey for us that's cool so who
all came on the trip with you
my parents and um our baby is over there
yeah okay all right cool all right your
baby's name is what asher now do you
want asher in the shot for this or yeah
yeah
all right cool very cool good good good
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that is the next chapter in your
story for sure you've changed your
family tree way to go you guys excellent
job and a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away when
someone at thanksgiving mentions that
they need some help you'll have a book
you can hand them very good stuff blake
and macy and asher asher's life has been
changed by his mom and dad
dallas texas 66 000 paid off in 15
months making 133 to 143. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two
[Applause]
i love it
i love it
well at the break we're going to
interview asher about the psychological
damage of having been brought home from
the hospital into a used baby bed yeah
you can just see the little guy scarred
right there he looks like he's struggled
yeah he looks it looks like
the wallpaper on the wall was not right
in that nursery i'm just saying there's
there's a permanent damage done here
didn't have a brand those parents should
be ashamed what do they call those
things that like
thank you dave
dave knows baby baby forgotten all the
babies dave's got all the baby stuff
dialed in now yeah including the
expensive nurseries although i didn't
write a single check for any of them but
um i am privy to the process toured all
of them i've toured all of them at
lengths at various times of day and even
into the evenings yes it has happened so
yeah that's it's uh
but i i hey same thing happened when the
ramsey kids were coming home a million
years ago or the coleman kids you got to
have a got to have a special room gotta
have a special thing but we in america
go nuts what we spend on our pets
would support egypt oh
don't even get me started on that one i
love my pets and you love yours too
but man oh man what we spend on
halloween
what americans spend on halloween
would do away from with hunger for most
of the people in america that have
hunger issues
by the way the kids these days dave are
getting full-sized candy bars i grew up
in their old days when we got a little
t-shirt
half of a bite that's what's wrong with
the world just saying it's just a spool
it's just awful it's just awful
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well you're hearing all these debt-free
screams and you're thinking about fall
stuff you got to buy like halloween
candy and jackets and sweaters christmas
is coming up christmas sneaks up on
people every year like they move it or
something it's always in december i'll
just put christmas on a credit card
again what do you think you are in
congress
hey when you plan ahead with a budget
you can keep christmas from getting out
of control and the best way to do that
is with our world-class budgeting tool
every dollar
and you can sync up with that and go
through financial peace university at
ramsey plus with a ramsey plus
membership and every dollar working
along with uh financial peace university
inside ramsey plus gives you everything
you want stress free
you can get control you can be the these
people you were just listening to start
budgeting with every dollar by texting
budget to 33
789
text budget to 33789
dan is with us in hudson wisconsin hey
dan welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thank you how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
um i just want to give you and ken and
your team a huge shout out my wife and i
recently became a hundred percent
debt-free
here we go everything so
we are super grateful for all you and
your team do
um my question
tonight on baby step seven
um part of what we're doing we're
self-employed we have a small business
is to up the contributions for our
buy raise for our employees
we currently have a simple ira we're
matching three percent
and
i was told that three percent of the max
that we can do in a simple ira that's
true um
okay and then
would it be worth going into a 401k and
i was
how many employees do you have
we have six
uh
talk with your smartvestor pro
about this the simple ira is a 401k for
small business but it is very um
structured it requires that you put in
three percent no more no less
uh as a match and it's 100 vested from
day one for anybody that goes in
uh the 401k could cost you as much as
five or ten thousand dollars a year in
administrative fees and across five or
six employees that seems like a waste
so it might be the way to do this is
with a sep
ira you can do that in addition to
the simple ira the sep
plan the simplified employee pension
plan
says any employee that's been with you
three more than three of the last five
years you are required to put into that
the same percentage of your income that
you put in for you
that's why a lot of people don't use it
so it works really good for a
solopreneur
like if i want to just dump a bunch of
money into a retirement plan but if i've
got employees been with me more than
three the last five years and i put in
15 of my income i have to put in 15 of
their income for them
and so you're wanting to do that so this
might work really well for you you know
you're not required to put in any amount
but and you can change it year to year
so you could come up on the end of the
year and go hey this year i'm going to
put in seven percent of my income and
i'm putting in seven percent of
everybody else's in addition to doing
the simple
okay and so you the good news about it
is it would give you flexibility you
don't have to do anything
uh depending on how your profits go that
year and you could decide
you know you could do a little bit
through the year and then pop it up at
the end
and you know jack the numbers up at the
end of the year if you wanted to so
check with your smartvestor pro
if you're not working with one go to
ramseysolutions.com and click smart
vester those are the people we recommend
in the investment world it'll drop down
a list of the ones in your area you can
pick one from that list and they'll all
be people that we have vetted and people
that have the heart of a teacher very
cool when a guy has six employees and
wants to make sure he's taking care of
their retirement
brings up the old phrase dave you said a
billion times if you live like no one
else later you can live and give like no
one else and this is the backbone of
america right here there's a young man
they've done the hard work they've
they've become debt-free now he wants to
pour into his employees
i mean that's phenomenal yeah that right
there no one requiring no he's calling
and asking
yeah it goes past it was not a a a an
executive order no it was not the irs
looking into his bank account no
it wasn't any of that stuff it was just
a guy who did well and thought you know
i want to share with the team
that helped me get here yeah and um
knowing that they could leave and take
that money with them yeah they can at
any time that's the rule
but uh what a great heart i love that
yes robert is with us in california hey
robert welcome to the ramsey show
hello um
yeah so uh my question is very related
to um ken's book that he's been working
on and um
basically i have two job offers um both
really good offers but one of them is
substantially higher than the other and
um
the one that's higher is working for a
really big tech corporation um that i
wouldn't necessarily be super excited
about uh and the one that's lower is a
job i'd be much more excited about but
it's a lot lower it's like uh 70 000
left so i'm wondering what are the two
numbers
uh it's like
240 total compensation versus 170.
doing what
software development for the tech
corporation what's the other option the
170 240 and 170.
yeah but what's the what kind is it both
tech jobs tech development yeah they're
both software which one's a big company
yeah they're both
software development but the the smaller
uh the lower one of the smaller company
that's doing work that i think is
actually interesting where i would be
much more excited to like go to my job
every day as opposed to
exactly all right so let's ask this
question for that company
you're more excited is there a ladder
what does it look like a year two three
years down the line if you take the 170
doing the work that you're interested in
so they've definitely assured me that
there's a ladder but it's a little
harder to find information on how much
of a ladder there is because the
companies the this the lower salary one
that i'm more excited about is only a
year and a half old as a company so
there's not a lot of information on how
the ladder's been for other people yeah
what do you make currently you've got
two offers what are you currently making
i currently make about 130. so they're
both they're both
increases obviously one's a huge
increase so yeah let me ask you this if
if both of them were the same pay which
one would you choose
oh i would definitely choose the smaller
company by far if they're the same thing
so to me though this is the advice i
give dave may disagree and he wouldn't
be wrong but i have talked to enough
people on the ken coleman show and the
ramsay show that have taken the
promotion or taken an offer that was
more money
and they'll call me back and they'll say
i took it
and i'm miserable now or i don't have
the meaning i wish i was doing the other
work and i think that you've got to
remove the money from the equation
because you're not going backwards on
either and you've got to say what is it
that i want to do why do i enjoy option
two
more than option one and if there is a
ladder it seems that there is i'm always
gonna say
follow your heart and do the work that
you're excited about if there is a
ladder and it sounds like there so
that's where i would go because i think
money's not enough to sustain you
completely agree only i'm going to do a
modified option one i'm going to go back
in and go guys uh my heart is here this
is what i want to do i love what you're
doing i want to be plugged in i got this
other offer for 240.
help me figure out a way to come here
yeah so i mean they probably they're not
going to go to 240. i didn't say that
i didn't say you had to match it i just
said help me figure out a way to come
here
and then they you know and it could it
could be that they very clearly outline
a detailed ladder on a calendar yes it
could be that they offer you stock
options in this startup that are worth a
whole heck of a lot more than 70.
right that's true they can give you some
points in the deal the stock is going to
be worth you take you a couple deal
points and and you take this job yeah
but you go back in and you ju you just
smile and you just say i really want to
come here help me figure out a way
right that's a great point and then just
let them squirm and start answering that
question that don't you don't tell them
what the answer is
and here's what's going to happen a
they're going to give you a more more
than 170. b they're going to offer a
ladder or something like that and c they
may even offer you points in the deal
and none of those are on the table today
and
one simple question shut up let this let
the let the pressure fall in the room on
the other side of the table
gently kindly say
i really want to come here
these other people are offering me 240.
help me figure out a way to come
and i promise you it will not result in
anything but more money in this
conversation it's a wonderful
negotiating tool it'll work for it'll
just just hey man that phone call's
worth 20 grand shut up and this show's
free
there you go
you don't get this anywhere else in
america i can tell you that
ken coleman good hour thank you sir for
having me
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice and the paid off student loan
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice george camel
ramsey personality host of the fine
print a new podcast out on ramsey
networks is my co-host for this very
special theme hour
on the ramsey show as we celebrate the
launch of the new documentary borrowed
future we're going to talk student loans
this hour if you want to talk about
student loans you got a question about
student loans you have a success story
about student loans you think they're
awesome you think they're the most
horrible thing on the planet uh you have
an opinion about anything you want to
talk about as long as that's that
subject you call triple eight eight two
five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five borrowed future is out of
the gate it has launched george and it's
already moving the needle and it's it's
climbing the charts and for good reason
i've already seen the feedback one woman
said she's watched it twice already
before 9 a.m that's impressive she was
so fired up about this she's telling
everyone about it her daughter all of
her friends it's one of those that you
can't help but you have to tell everyone
you need to go watch this today if you
don't know what borrowed future is it's
our new documentary it launches today on
apple tv on google play and on amazon
prime
and you can also watch it at borrowed
future dot com and if you're a teacher
you can it's all a standard documentary
it's what 4.99 to rent it whatever 8.99
to buy it or whatever the normal thing
is on that stuff and uh just like
anything else you look to see a first
class documentary on something this is
all about the student loan
world
how the student how student loans are
basically killing the american dream
it's called borrowed future be sure you
tune into it again amazon prime google
play apple tv is number two in the
documentary already today
of all documentaries on apple yeah so
it's moving you guys are watching it
like crazy you're sharing it if you're a
teacher and you want to show this to
your students it's free go to borrowed
future.com i'm going to tell you that
about a hundred times this hour but it's
time to talk about these student loans
and how out of control they are george
did you have a student loan yeah i had
36 000 it was i think the average at the
time so i was very average hmm
how long it took you to pay it off uh 18
months once i got on this plane once you
got serious about it you knocked it out
fast yeah
i didn't realize you could get rid of
them i just thought it's something you
just keep as a pet uh until your adult
life and maybe take it to the grave if
you have to yeah i had 3 200
wow way back there it was 1982 right
and um
yeah and i had way more than that on my
amaco card
my gas credit card because in those days
if you went out in the country you could
buy a couch on your gas credit card i
mean it was you know crazy stuff so uh
but yeah it was a different different
world and certainly tuition was
different and
but uh so was the cost of living
gasoline was under a dollar yeah wow
that i got one and that kind of thing so
that's how long ago that 1982 was for
you people but uh student loans have
continued to grow to where it has become
an uh just a weight
on people to where they can't breathe
it's just so normal i mean most people
you meet that's the one thing you're
going to have in common is oh you've got
a student loan too great how much is
yours and then you laugh about it
because you can't fathom because you
can't cry about it but only so much
exactly if you when you can't cry you
laugh and so this is a huge issue and as
we explored this two years ago while we
were doing the borrowed future podcast
which you hosted which i hosted the
documentary team was just getting
started on this so this was two years
ago
and watching that team develop the story
and iterate and iterate to tell the
right story has been absolutely
incredible well we're storytellers here
and i got to tell you when you're
telling a story there's a process to
telling a story uh if you're going to do
it properly there's a villain
there's a hero there's a guide
and there's a story arc
and there's a process you build to pull
someone through a story and we had a
serious problem
with this documentary there were too
many villains
there are villains everywhere you don't
know who to point the finger at
is it sally may is it the guidance
counselors is it the parents is it the
student loan company
person who signed up for the loan the
person who signed up there's kind of
hard to blame them although they did
sign up for it but they're in just such
a pitiful horrible situation
and you want to cry with them rather
than beat them up yeah yeah we're not
mad at you if you took out the students
i mean i'm not mad at it you know i am
mad at the banks i think they're out of
control um you know there's only been
two or three times in my career 30 years
here on the air that elizabeth warren
and i have agreed on something
and uh because i'm a capitalist pig and
she's a socialist
um and uh she's a very bright lady and
i've actually had her on the air here
back in the day we were fighting a
bankruptcy bill that the republicans put
through
uh at the behest of the bankers and it
was a bad bill and it's a bad law and
it's still in place
uh modification is the bankruptcy law
and she and i were on the same side of
that ted kennedy was
the three of us were fighting against
that and we all lost of course
uh and but she's come out today and and
of course if you haven't heard uh
naviant uh six million student loan
borrowers are far better off after yet
another major company announced it will
shut down its services elizabeth warren
said like like elizabeth warren calls
navient to shut down come on elizabeth
you didn't cause this but yeah no one uh
no one is crying a tear that navient is
gone navient one of the largest student
loan companies unveiled plans to end its
federal loan services the student loan
industry on tuesday received yet another
major shake-up when navient became the
third company to announce
its plans to end its federal student
loan program amid regulatory crackdowns
this year
senator elizabeth warren had one message
for the company good riddance
i would agree with you senator warren
navient has spent decades misleading
cheating and abusing student borrowers
the federal student loan program will be
far better off without them
the federal student loan program would
be far better off if it didn't exist
senator warren it has not been a
blessing to anyone except people like
navient and people like you
who used it to get votes
navient which collects the federal
student loan debt of 6 million borrowers
said in a press release that it's
working with the education department to
approve the transition of those
borrowers to another loan company called
maximus that's it that's a villainous
comforting
that's a comforting maximus what
interest
maximus interest that's scary
maximus screw job
so you just get traded to the next one
you can't make this up
they're gonna call it maximus
oh boy this is fabulous
this is what's wild richard cordray head
of the federal student aid office he
said
earlier this month student loan
companies are choosing to shut down
rather than face more accountability
yeah that's what's going on because
they've been screwing people they go hey
this ship is sinking let's get out of
here we we don't got caught with our
hand in the cookie jar we got all the
cookies out of this we're gonna get
we're gone baby we're gonna get out of
here before we end up the subject of a
federal investigation and get more than
shut down yeah that's what that's what's
going on they're not doing anyone favors
but themselves here yeah and i got to
tell you the democrats and the
republicans
did put pressure on navient for its
misbehavior and thank you i will go
along with you senator warren
good riddance to naviant
ciao baby
student loans we're bringing people from
across the aisle today bring all maximus
bring all maximus
maximus and trust us
maximus
that's
penalties event maximus penalties oh i
can't believe it
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
it's a student loan theme hour we're
talking student loans in honor of
today's premier launch of the new
documentary borrowed future
you can view it anywhere you view great
documentaries like google play
amazon prime apple tv and it borrowed
future.com stockton is with us in
phoenix arizona hey stockton welcome to
the ramsey show
good afternoon um i graduated graduate
school
a year ago with two hundred thousand
dollars student debt at seven percent
my question is the recommendation is to
get out of debt except for a home the
home debt is okay what if my student
loans is as much as a home would cost is
the recommendation to still
pay off the student loans renting during
that time and if so that'll be
10 plus years
what's your graduate degree in
i'm a chiropractor
okay
and so what are you going to be making
i just started a job here in phoenix 85
thousand a year
okay and so you you plan to pay fifteen
thousand dollars a year on the student
loans
yes
well that sucks
yeah
that's pretty lame you ought to pay a
lot more than 15 000 if you're making 80
and you should be making more than 80 as
your chiropractic career grows would you
agree with me
yeah the hope is definitely to make more
eventually um as i grow in the company
and whatnot the other issue what did you
make but the year before you graduated
what was your income
50 000 um associates in chiropractic
don't can be taken advantage of and i
was last year so i didn't make very good
money last year yeah okay so what if you
lived on 35 000
and put the rest of it towards the
student loan debt
yeah um that was one of the reasons why
we postponed getting a home is is to
hopefully throw more money at the
student loans the only issue is to live
in a rental home where my wife and our
kids feel comfortable walking the street
our rental is 1600 a month and that
doesn't include the administration fees
the hoa fees and other fees associated
with
the renting so that's something that i
struggle with is being able to throw all
my money at student loans yet my rental
i feel like is taking more money than it
should i'll tell you as as a homeowner
it's very expensive and i'm not talking
about the mortgage payment versus the
rent payment i'm talking about home
ownership in general so if you can't
afford to rent you definitely can't
afford to be a homeowner and so what i
want you to do is focus on these student
loans first i want you to buy a house i
want you to have that american dream but
as we talk about in the documentary
student loans are killing that dream
because you've got this bear of a
payment in your life and you've got a
great income it's going to continue to
go up and like dave saying this thing's
gone three and three to four years from
now stockton here's the thing
you have two choices you can go the way
that you're you're trying to your
emotions are taking you where you're
justifying this and you're figuring out
a way that it takes forever and so you
go ahead and buy a house and now you've
got a house payment and you've got the
cost of home ownership that georgia's
talking about and your career will move
along and it will take you 10 years to
get out of that or more
if you go that route or you can do the
thing that we have taught and many many
chiropractors have done what i teach
and they roll up their sleeves and they
say not today i'm going to engage in a
different
treatment program for the patient i'm
going to roll up my sleeves we're going
to do nothing around this house we're
not going to do anything except get out
of debt we're going to clean up this
mess so that as my career grows i get to
actually keep the freaking money instead
of sending it all to sallie mae navient
or maximus
so uh
[Music]
this is going to be too much fun i'm
looking forward to the next decade of
this well and so uh yeah the uh uh yeah
you but right now the the state of mind
you're in you're gonna be in debt a long
time because you bought the lie that
you're stuck and you bought the lie that
you might as well just keep this like
it's a freaking backache or you can do
the i just told a chiropractor like
i just said that i did that on purpose
that was a metaphor that he would
understand and so yeah the uh i hope so
you you're gonna either engage in the
extreme measures
to get the extreme results or you're
gonna be normal
and i sound like you talking to one of
your patients
with the treatment program you put in so
you got to decide
physician heal thyself
sierra is with us sierra is in
whoa what did i do there she's in uh did
i did i i gotcha didn't i got it i
managed to pull it off in san antonio
hey sierra how are you
i'm good how are you good now to back
story for our listeners you were here
just the other day with your parents who
did their debt-free scream they were
amazing you were amazing and we called
you back because of while they're doing
their debt-free screaming talking about
getting out of debt they said and oh by
the way
our daughter who was going into college
while we're getting out of debt
managed to go and get her degree debt
free
and you're an impressive young lady i
remember remember meeting you the other
day thanks for coming on with us
thank you for having me i really
appreciate it it was a lot of fun being
able to uh watch my parents tell their
story and then now i get the chance this
online so i'm super excited cool so your
degree is in what
i got a degree in marketing from where
stephen at austin state university in
nacogdoches texas acting jacks there you
go and you
did this 100 debt free
how weird are you how did you do that
yeah so um it really all started with a
plan
that my dad and i put together
my senior year of high school
it was getting down to the wire i pretty
much had
my own plan actually figured out i
thought i did at the time
i had the school i wanted to go to i had
the acceptance letter i had you know
room and board figured out um
i just didn't have the money to pay for
it so that was uh the biggest uh thing
that i had to figure out
and so you know my parents sat me down
and they were like look you know we want
you to go to school we're just not going
to go into debt in order for you to do
that and so i kind of had to just come
into terms with the fact that
i wasn't going to have that first year
college experience that i was looking
forward to but there was a bigger
picture at hand and so my dad and i
devised a plan
and
we basically figured out how much it was
going to take or how much i would have
to save to go to the university of my
choice which was sfa
for the last two years so four semesters
we got that number and then we figured
out how much i needed to be saving
monthly
in order to reach that goal at the end
of my first two years at my community
college and so while i went to community
college for the first two years i worked
i would say at least 40 hours a week
every week and i was saving pretty much
my entire check what were you doing what
kind of work
oh i worked at a local grocery store and
you were how old
i was 17 at the time so 17 18 years old
you're in community college for the
first two years and you're working in
saving to do the last two years at your
dream school
correct wow
right is that what happened
yes i did i was making about um i want
to say maybe 13 an hour um and i was
able to actually finish a community
college a little bit early i finished in
three semesters instead of four
um because of the high school credits
that i took
i mean the college credits that i took
in high school um i was able to finish
up so you did like some ap classes that
got college credit
correct they were like dual credit card
which sped up how fast you got through
and was made you did not take those
classes or saved your money
correct ding ding ding ding ding ding
wow
yeah so that helped me out a lot i was
able to finish an entire semester early
at community college so that last
semester i just worked i mean i was
working every day every night i actually
ended up taking on a second job because
the one job that i had i wasn't going to
reach my goal in time when did you
graduate
i graduated
i graduated high school 2016 finished
community college in 2018 and then
graduated um
from sfa this past may 2020. you got the
new marketing job
not yet
currently i work at ernst young one of
the big four accounting firms as a
financial analyst
right now but without the the birth of
your mic
i make about forty seven thousand family
i love you you're amazing incredible
incredible okay key point
made a plan my dad
was a parent
my dad did two things
he took dead off the table
not an option
my dad
helped me plan you picked up on it
george yeah she made a plan
rachel cruz says we don't have a student
loan crisis we have a parenting crisis i
believe that moms and dads are letting
their 18 year olds run off into a ditch
and watching them do it
instead of grabbing you and going no
debt plan no debt plan work
sounds like dad's stuff sounds like mom
stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's a student loan theme hour here on
the ramsey show open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
george campbell if you want to talk
about student loans this is your place
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host he is the current host uh he was
the original host of the borrowed future
podcast which actually gave us the uh
inspiration and the idea to turn it all
into a documentary and george did a
great job with that millions and
millions of you have listened to
borrowed future podcast uh i think it
was 10 12 episodes yeah it was eight and
now nine we released a bonus one today
oh bonus episode on the podcast today
yeah updating everyone to go with the
launch on the documentary and of course
he's also the host of the new ramsey
network's production called the fine
print
and you can listen to him there all the
time i want to go back to sierra's story
for a minute she's incredible
a young lady comes in says i'm gonna go
to college and i have no idea how i'm
gonna pay for it and there's no way i
have the money as if the money's going
to just rain from heaven which is you
you were interviewing some students some
high school students recently and you
started asking them and it freaked them
all out basic questions what it was
going to cost
what do they want to do what was it
going to cost how are they going to pay
for it and you would have thought it was
an interrogation room and i went oh my
gosh
their parents have never talked to them
about this stuff well their parents have
never thought about it either
that's matters
and that you can get a job because you
paid money to get a degree
not i got a degree in left-handed
puppetry and then i'm shocked that i'm
serving coffee
come on
moms and dads you got better sense than
this
but sierra's dad said no you're going to
study marketing
consequently she's got a job straight
out of college making almost 50 grand
and that young woman there she'll be
making double that in just a handful of
years i promise you
uh she's uh
incredible and then the second thing dad
did was he said no
we're not gonna borrow money which means
that we need a plan
we need a plan so how are we going to do
this where she worked her tail end off
oh by the way working while you're in
college is not child abuse
call the wambulance
you don't get to participate in the beer
pong tournament you'll survive
you're there to get a degree to gather
knowledge this is what you're paying for
not how much alcohol you can consume
and whether the football team is good or
not will not affect your future career
they don't ask about that when you do
the job interview who knew
who knew
you know
yeah it's conversation piece oh you went
to so-and-so and they suck at football
that's the only thing that comes up and
then they move right along right oh my
god
you know and so the the the uh student
experience that we're paying 150 grand
for
somebody shoot me and get this over with
really
instead we're going to end up with
maximus debt as us
that's the new lender maximus debt is us
navies
i just renamed the whole thing i'm going
to have so much fun with this it's just
you're right it sounds like a villain
from a saturday morning cartoon maximus
debt of the that is us yeah i love it
it's frightening
so parents moms and dads you can stop
this watch borrowed future scare you
straight scare your kids straight
and it'll also make you vote your
congressman out of office because
they're idiots they keep the student
loan thing in place and then they go
around we need to forgive student loans
well student loans are so evil elizabeth
warren that we need to forgive them she
tweeted that today by the way if we need
to forgive the student loans elizabeth
warren why aren't you passing
legislation to stop making them
oh that would be intellectually
dishonest oh wait a minute you're a
politician oh wait a minute you're a
democrat oh my god seriously
huh are you riled up i'm riled up
we did it i have for 30 years worked
with people whose lives have been
screwed up by this
and it doesn't affect me at all yeah i
don't have student loans
like i said 3 200
500 years ago when the dinosaurs roam
the earth nobody cares about my student
loan debt but i tell you what talking
these people their lives unbelievable
carol is with us carol is in
philadelphia carol your student loan
question or comment
uh hi thank you for having me um i just
had a comment about uh student loans and
my back story i am 46 years old and i
still have
101 000
left in student loans i was double dumb
and went back to college twice and took
out loans twice
um i just didn't know any better
before you know following dave ramsey
and personalities yeah
i still have to rent an apartment um i
only have a thousand dollars in my
emergency fund
i've never really fully been able to
invest i always thought investing was
you know for the rich people um and it's
just from my background neither of my
parents went to college they had no idea
what you know they could never teach me
what were your degrees in
well the first degree was in history
which if you don't go to grad school and
you don't want to be a teacher um is
basically like left-handed puppetry um
when you graduate so
and then i worked in an office in my um
20s and then in my 30s i decided to go
back i always wanted to be an architect
so i got an architecture degree um but i
went to a private school yes yes i'm
doing financially well
do you make next year
i am making 80 000. that's good okay so
now we're going to claw our way out of
this okay good
exactly exactly so um but i just would
tell anybody
don't take out student loans at all it's
not a good roi you know sallie mae is
not in my spare bedroom i'm living in
her basement it feels like right now
you know so she owns the house i'm just
a tenant yes
exactly exactly um
and i i think people are so
they want to get done in four years and
they want to start their life and you
know at 17 and 18 i didn't know what i
want to do most people don't know what
they want to do at that age i think it's
better to take your time
work you know build your savings to be
able to go it's okay to go to school
part-time you don't need to go to the
party school you don't need to
live away from home it's just
you really have to think about it i wish
they would have taught it in high school
um
so yeah it's it's tough it's it's not
easy
carol i'm proud of you for facing the
monster i think you're going to win i
think you've turned the corner
i will win my goal is to get it all paid
off before i'm 50 because i do not want
student loans in my 50s there you go
that's a good that's a good goal and
you're gonna get there i mean it's four
years you're gonna make it you're gonna
do it that's 25 000 a year making 80
grand you can do that
and um i i got faith in you and thank
you for telling your story though
because it is a wake-up call and again
we go back to
studying something that's applicable
sean got an architecture degree now that
actually works hello
and studying something studying at a
school
see here's the thing okay
i'm not mad at you if you want to go to
a famous school and pay a lot of money
i mean 70 80 000 a year okay vanderbilt
right here in nashville 70 something
thousand bucks a year
tuition
okay university of tennessee
in-state tuition state school twelve
thousand dollars
so is vander are we saying vanderbilt is
seven times your income's gonna be seven
times as much if you go to vanderbilt as
if you go ut
well i know this is not a fact because i
went to the university of tennessee and
people that weren't with the vanderbilt
work for me
so i know the 7x thing doesn't work
and oh will i make connections with what
other broke people
who are you connecting with
other people who didn't have the ability
to look for a value now again i'm not
i've got relatives that graduate from
vanderbilt they're very smart and
vanderbilt is academically superior it's
not 7x superior no not even close
not even close and if you go
300 000 in debt to go there it's an
indication you're not superior
yeah your your lack of judgment is
unbelievable and so i'm picking on
vanderbilt but they're just an example
of one of the famous schools that's a
they're the southern ivy league if you
want to call it there's a lot of pride
and you went my mom and dad went there
and so i've got to go hard to get into
it's right it's a very it's prestigious
the football team well maybe not there's
not there but a lot of times you make
these decisions based on where mom and
dad went what the experience is going to
be like what the football team is like
not can we afford it and is this going
to get me the degree that i can get the
job in the field that i'm passionate
about we're not thinking that way we
took a call here on the air just a few
months ago a young lady in south
carolina was talking about going to
oxford to mississippi and i said why are
you going to mississippi instead of
south carolina it's 14 000 or more
because of out-of-state tuition
a reason the town is pretty
ah
i'm gonna lose my mind
where are your parents
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first peter 5 6 and
7 7 humble yourselves therefore under
god's mighty hand that he may lift you
up in due time cast all your anxiety on
him because he cares for you
martin luther king said no work is
insignificant all labor that uplifts
humanity has dignity and importance and
should be undertaken with painstaking
excellence
george campbell is my co-host today this
is a student loan hour as we celebrate
the premier launch today
of our first documentary it's called
borrowed future
how student loans are killing the
american dream you can watch it on apple
tv
rent it for 4.99 google play amazon
prime or borrowed future dot com or you
can buy it and download it like you
would a great documentary of other kinds
so be sure and check that out darnell is
with us in
huh raleigh north carolina hey darnell
what's up
hey dave i'm will how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
yeah so um i was calling because i just
finished watching the ball feature
documentary and it's gotten me thinking
about my student loans and my repayment
plan i'm especially considering that i'm
going to be graduating soon and i'll
have to start paying them
um
so so far my student loans have been
kind of in the background one because
you know i have four years to work on
paying them well to consider how i would
pay them
but i also went back to school right
after so um
so they've really been in the background
for a while but after watching the
documentary
it's kind of gotten me thinking of what
the best repayment plan is yeah how much
student loan debt do you have
right now i have 38 000 and i'm going to
have to accept another 5000 to finish
off okay she had 45 000 give or take by
the time all the smoke clears and your
degree is going to be in what
um this will be my master of the
business administration good good okay
when will you graduate
uh may of 22.
okay all right and so well between now
and then what i'd prefer you do is work
your tail end off and let's see if we
can not take out any more loans won't
you see if you can cash flow the rest of
it that's the first thing let's stop
doing harm and then from there george
when he gets out and gets the job yeah
as soon as you get a job uh that money
is not going to go to you it's going to
go to lenders and you're going to work
your tail off probably get a second job
and get rid of this debt it's 43k if
you've got an mba and you're making 50
60k
you can get rid of this debt in two
years or less yeah
exactly so it's possible you don't have
to be beans and rice rice and beans dude
you don't come out and buy a new car you
don't come out and buy a house you don't
come out and spend a bunch of money you
don't come out and act like your top dog
you're not your bottom dog you got 45
grand about in student loan debt you got
to clean up and that's so that's mission
one the quicker you knock that out the
quicker you get on with the rest of your
life and you get to benefit from this
education
the longer you keep this around it's
more going to be like trying to swim
with concrete concrete shoes on don't do
it we just took that call from the 46
year old still paying on her loans i
don't want that to be you darnell i want
you to have your entire adult life
student loan free
good observation
nadia is with us in houston texas hi
nadia
hi it's nadia nadia i messed it up i'm
sorry okay nadia my bad i remember
seeing you the other day on my
daughter's show rachel cruz
and you were impressive and i told them
to reach out and see if you would come
on thank you for doing that thank you
for having me now you went through
school debt-free tell us your story
right quick
absolutely i actually got my start in
community college through bureaucratic
courses when i was in high school i
started at 12 graduated from my with my
associates when i finished high school
at 16 and then went to my four-year
university finished off my four-year
degree in another two years and
graduated debt-free at 18.
with a degree in what
political science okay what are you
doing
uh right now i'm actually saving up
money so i can cash flow for grad school
and in hopes to become either a social
worker or social worker or a child
advocacy lawyer
okay
i like b
because i think you're incredible i i
was watching you're you're why i watched
your presence and your poise on the air
with rachel it was absolutely and you
currently are 20 years old
i'm no sir i'm 18. 18 years old i'm
sorry yeah and uh you attributed this if
i recall to uh your mom and dad being
immigrants
um absolutely the drive my parents
placed in me was
you you are going to college you're
going to do it and we're going to make
it happen uh but you need to do your
part and apply the scholarship whenever
you can
yeah well you got your undergrad at 18.
that's that's i think that's doing your
part so your mom and dad immigrated from
where jamaica from jamaica and they said
we're coming to america we're going to
change our family tree so by god you're
doing this
yes absolutely and one thing i
appreciate is they would never
helicopter parents because i know so
many people their parents are just on
them so much they don't have any room to
grow my parents are always like you know
what you need to do make sure you handle
your business and then we don't need to
be overbearing in any way they treated
you like an adult
absolutely i was 12 in in the community
college i was taking classes with adults
so well they're in that respect and kept
it yes sir so you're are you uh have you
been tested for intelligence are you
like a savant or something
i haven't i did skip two grades
kindergarten and first grade so i went
from preschool to second that was the
last time i took an educational test
like that
i can't skip lunch and she's just
skipping grades over here
you are very impressive
you're incredible well i think you've
got i think you've got a high level of
intelligence but i think you've got a
higher level of uh drive
and really and that comes from a higher
power yes absolutely yeah no question no
question god being involved in your
all's lives and uh if you guys want to
hear more of uh nadia did i say it right
that time you sure did dia's story you
can see rachel here on rachel cruz's
show uh on youtube uh which comes up
pretty regularly that's where i picked
it up and i was just thumbing through
rachel's show and i went whoa look at
this young lady she's amazing so uh the
ke your your
thing was you worked your tail off you
went to community college you got school
credit for school classes you were
taking you rolled that up so you didn't
have to take as many classes
and you do the whole thing in four years
now did you get all scholarships or were
you working to pay for it
uh i actually got my first job when i
was already a junior at howard
university and i used that to pay off
some of my books and things and just
additional expenses due to the pandemic
but i didn't get a full ride from howard
a lot of it was external scholarships
like i mentioned on the show i'm not the
product of like these big 10 20 30 000
scholarships i'm the product of 50
scholarships and 100
and 200 because a lot of people snubbed
their nose at those but i was the person
like if there's any scholarship y'all
are going to give me i will apply take
my chances and keep collecting the
winnings so out of the total how many
dollars in scholarships did you collect
do you think
i don't know the exact amount but i know
with the other schools that i didn't
choose to attend in total the last time
i checked was over two million dollars
offered when you considered like the
tuition and full rides from other
schools i was offering but the actual
when you add up all those fifty dollar
ones and all that and actual cash
dollars that went towards your school
well you think it's ten thousand or
fifty thousand
it's probably closer to the 50 000 10.
yeah wow and how many different
scholarships do you think you had you
said you had a lot of little ones
well over 50
yeah so they averaged under a thousand
dollars a piece yeah is the point yeah
that's what it's not about
20 000 scholarships and full rides
you've got to apply for the little ones
it adds up guys this can be done
you just have to pay attention and when
you don't pay attention to any area of
your life including your education your
kids education including your wealth
including your debt you wake up and
you're normal and your life sucks
and these people that have wanted this
were not zombies they did not sleepwalk
they paid attention their dads and moms
paid attention so this is what borrowed
futures about it's trying to get america
to pay attention to an epic
and epic failure called the student loan
program it is a failure it needs to stop
yeah you've got to make a decision once
you watch this documentary you have to
decide if you're going to be a part of
this system any longer if you're going
to let your kids be a part of that
system and your friends be part of that
system so every living breathing person
needs to watch this documentary the
stories are inspiring there's some
heartbreaking stuff there's some amazing
experts featured on there and it's 90
minutes and it is a world-class feature
film documentary i'm so proud of this
team and what impact this is going to
have yeah me too borrowed future again
you can watch it at google play amazon
prime and apple tv as well as borrow
future.com if you are a teacher show it
to your class for free
uh and so far today we've had several
hundred teachers already sign up for
that which gives me hope you can do that
we gonna stir up our ruckus boys and
girls
check it out that puts us our the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you